[Music]
Jack I can only imagine what's going on
in your head right now
[Music]
every day you're on the Run you're
digging a hole that you may not be able
to get out
[Music]
I'm not running from the CIA
then why are they chasing you
a small group of hard-line Russians
formed a plan to preserve USSR use a
nuclear strike to create chaos the
weapon has been built and it is on the
move
the US can't go anywhere near this we
don't have any living room to make
mistakes
don't come in you will be recalled I
come in now a whole lot of people are
gonna die
across the line and there may be no
going back because I'm trying to do the
right thing
there's never just about a nuke this is
about starting a World War
I was playing the dirty things just
Escape
Jack every second man is
[Music]
Jack if you've got a plan the time is
now
I want Jack Ryan in custody immediately
so what are the odds this is a one-way
trip 80 90 that's my last flight won't
be in coach
foreign
[Music]